none of this has ever been attempted
before flying how the copter takes a lot
of skill to put someone like Tom into a
situation like this is almost impossible
to imagine he came to me and he said
we're gonna go to Airbus and we're gonna
learn how to fly a helicopter and be at
2,000 our pilot in a very short period
of time take something like three months
of eight-hour days just to become a
novice helicopter pilot Tom needs to
work around the clock to reach the level
of skill the sequence means there very
few students that have his level of
dedication and focus thank you
almost aerial chases you'll see from a
helicopter we don't usually turn the
cameras in so we've developed these rigs
over the last couple months when we can
basically hard mount two cameras to show
that Ethan Hunt is flying the helicopter
without anybody else every camera
position has been designed so that you
can see that tom is doing everything
himself it's super important for a movie
like mission to be doing it all
practically and for real Tom doesn't
want to it's in the green screen the
audience's can tell when something's
been cheated
for safety all the pilots get together
in the morning and they discuss very
clearly where they're gonna be and what
their positions are for every Shopp and
look down and I'll take it over the
waterfalls I enter it right away it's
great the most dangerous part of the
arrow sequence is really that there's
more than one helicopter in the air we
have 13 helicopters in the production
the ones on camera doing aerobatic just
a few feet from each other it's pretty
well throughout the entire sequence
visual contact
and then there's Todd he's a pilot he's
acting and who's the camera operator
it was the 360 downward spiral most
pilots with no tempest good corkscrew
turn is very challenging for a pilot it
takes a lot of skill a lot of practice
you make a mistake somebody's gonna die
from it I'm gonna go and each spiral
looks like he's going to crash
that's what I want Howard that's my cue
very upsetting here good trick
absolutely
you